JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you discussed some
of the inverse trigonometric
functions as part
of your discussion
of inverse functions in general
and implicit differentiation.
And I just wanted to
talk about one, briefly,
that you didn't mention in
lecture, as far as I recall,
which is the inverse cosine.
So what I'm going to call
the arccosine function.
So I just wanted to go
briefly through its graph
and its derivative.
So here I have the graph of
the curve y equals cosine x.
So this is a-- you
know, you should
have seen this before, I hope.
So it has-- at x equals 0
it has its maximum value 1.
And then to the
right it goes down.
Its first zero is at pi over 2.
And then it has its
trough at x equals pi.
And then it goes back up again.
And, OK, and it's
an even function
that looks the same to the right
and the left of the y-axis.
And it's periodic
with period 2 pi.
And it's also,
you know, what you
get by shifting
the sine function,
the graph of the sine function,
to the left by pi over 2.
So, OK, so this is
y equals cosine x.
So in order to graph
y equals arccosine
of x, we do what we do for
every inverse function,
which is we just take the
graph and we reflect it
across the line y equals x.
So I've done that over here.
So this is what we
get when we reflect
this curve-- the y equals cosine
x curve-- when we reflect it
through that diagonal
line, y equals x.
So one thing you'll
notice about this
is that it's not a function.
Right?
This curve is not the graph
of a function because every,
all these humps on
cosine x-- there
are more humps out here--
those horizontal lines cut
the humps in many points.
And when you reflect
you get vertical lines
that cut this curve
in many points.
So it doesn't pass the
vertical line test.
So in order to get a function
out of this, what we have to do
is we just have to take a
chunk of this curve that does
pass the vertical line test.
And so there are many,
many ways we could do this.
And we choose one
basically arbitrarily,
meaning we could make
a different choice,
and we could do all
of our trigonometry
around some other choice, but
it's convenient to just choose
one and if everyone agrees that
that's what that one is then we
can use it and it's nice.
We have a function and
we can-- the other ones
are all closely related to this
one choice that we can make.
So in particular
here, I think there's
an easiest choice,
which is we take
the curve y equals arccosine
x to be just this one
piece of the arc here.
So this has maximum-- so it
goes from x equals minus 1 to x
equals 1.
And when x is minus
1 we have y is pi,
and then when x equals 1 y is 0.
So this is the-- this curve
is the graph of the function y
equals arccosine of x.
And if you want-- so there's
a notation that mathematicians
use sometimes to show
that we're talking
about the particular
arccosine function that
has this as its domain
and this as its range.
So we sometimes write
arccosine and it
takes this domain-- the
values between 1 and 1--
and it spits out values
between 0 and pi.
So this is a sort
of fancy notation
that mathematicians use to say
the arc cosine function takes
values in the
interval minus 1, 1--
so it takes values
between negative 1 and 1--
and it spits out values
in the interval 0, pi.
So every value that it spits
out is between 0 and pi.
OK, so if you
graph the function,
so now this is a
proper function, right?
It's single-valued, it passes
the vertical line test.
So, OK.
And so that's the graph of
y equals arccosine of x.
So the other thing
that we did in lecture,
I think we talked about
arcsine and we graphed it.
And we talked about
arctan and we graphed it.
And we also computed
their derivatives.
So let's do that for
the arccosine, as well.
So, what have we got?
Well so, in order to
compute the derivative--
this function is defined
as an inverse function--
so we do the same
thing that we did
in lecture, which
is we use this trick
from implicit differentiation.
So in particular,
we have that if y
is equal to arccosine
of x then we can
take the cosine of both sides.
And cosine of
arccosine, since we've
chosen it as an inverse
function, that just gives us
back x.
So we get cosine
of y is equal to x.
And now we can differentiate.
So what we're after is the
derivative of arccosine
of x, so we're after dy/dx.
So we differentiate this
through with respect to x.
So on the right-hand
side we just get 1.
And on the left-hand
side, well, we
have a chain rule here, right?
Because we have cosine of
y, and y is a function of x.
So this is, so the derivative
of cosine is minus sine y,
and then we have to multiply
by the derivative of y,
which is dy/dx.
Now, dy/dx is the
thing we're after,
so we solve this
equation for dy/dx
and we get dy/dx is equal to
minus 1 divided by sine y.
OK, which is fine.
This is a nice formula,
but what we'd really like,
ideally, is to express
this back in terms of x.
And so we can, well we
can substitute, right?
We have an expression
for y in terms of x.
So that's y is equal
to arccosine of x.
So this is equal
to minus 1 divided
by sine of arccosine of x.
Now, this looks really ugly.
And here this is another
place where we could stop,
but actually it turns out that
because trigonometric functions
are nicely behaved we
can make this nicer.
So I'm going to appeal
here to the case
where x is between 0 and 1.
So then x, so then we
have a right triangle
that we can draw.
And the other case you
can do a similar argument
with a unit circle, but
I'll just do this one case.
So, if--
OK, so arccosine of x.
What does that mean?
That is the angle
whose cosine is x.
Right?
So if you draw a right triangle
and you make this angle arc--
two c's-- arccosine of x.
Well, that angle has
cosine equal to x so--
and this is a right triangle--
so it's adjacent side
over the hypotenuse
is equal to x,
and one easy way to get that
arrangement of things is
say this side is x
and the side is 1.
So OK.
So what?
Why do I care?
Because I need
sine of that angle.
So this is the angle arccosine
of x, so sine of that angle
is the opposite side
over the hypotenuse.
And what's the opposite side?
Well I can use the
Pythagorean theorem here,
and the opposite side is square
root of 1 minus x squared.
That's the length of
the opposite side.
So the sine of arccosine
of x is square root of 1
minus x squared divided by 1.
So sine of arccosine of x
is just square root of 1
minus x squared.
So we can write this in the
somewhat nicer form, minus 1
over the square root
of one minus x squared.
So if you remember what the
derivative of arcsine of x was,
you'll notice that this is a
very similar looking function.
And this is just because
cosine and sine are
very similar looking functions.
So in fact, the
graph of arccosine
is just a reflection of
the graph of arcsine,
and that's why the derivatives
are so closely related
to each other.
So OK, so there you go.
You've got the graph
of arccosine up there
and you've got the formula
for its derivative,
so that sort of
completes the tour
of the most important inverse
trigonometric functions.
So I think I'll end there.